I love cooking for mates but I never
made the mistake of doing complicated
formal food who wants to be stressed out
on the time off however I do have a
reputation to keep up so the food has
got to be good whether it's breakfast
brunch lunch or dinner here's my
ultimate food for friends
having people over for a bit of a late
breakfast or brunch at the weekend is a
brilliant way to catch up with friends
and this dish is always a winner
gorgeous griddle polenta with roasted
tomatoes and a creamy ghost curd I can't
wait to dive in next a lunch to knock
the socks off your mates Sensational
salt bait sea bream with easy braised
leeks and my middle daughter Holly gets
her hands dirty in the kitchen as we
cook a super simple dinner
guaranteed to be a hit with all your
loved ones stunning roast chicken
stuffed with aromatic chickpeas
a beautiful big green salad and an
amazing chocolate and hazelnut meringue
Tower
really good nice to see Holly get her
hands dirty right I think we all agree
oh this is my ultimate food for friends
breakfast lunch and dinner
first I said I suffocated late breakfast
or brunch dish to impress your mates
easy griddle polenta with delicious
roasted tomatoes and creamy goats curd
now polenta to the Italians is what
mashed potato is to Britain's a staple
incredibly delicious and really
straightforward to do now season the
water
it's a little touch of olive oil stops
it from becoming too sticky
I love polenta it's a cornmeal made from
ground dried maize
the more coarse the longer it takes to
cook but you can also buy instant
polenta which is ready in under 10
minutes and always use this at home
and then
whisk that out
as it Cooks out
it naturally thickens
you can see the grains becoming almost
into one nice fine pureed
polenta to take the polenta to another
level flavor wise season with salt and
pepper a good knob of butter and
parmesan I quite generous to the
parmesan because polenta can be quite
dull I like it quite rich and creamy
delicious
now mix that in
no a nice smooth shiny glossy plant you
can eat polenta two ways like this it's
a glorious fluffy Mash or set then
griddled which is what I'm doing
start by oiling a baking tray pour in
your polenta
now get that in the fridge and let it
set
next I'm roasting Vine tomatoes to
really intensify their flavor
olive oil on the bottom of the tray and
drizzle extra virgin olive oil on top
nip your tomatoes with your scissors if
you didn't burst them before they went
in the oven they'd explode so
and pepper garlic
just squeeze the juice out the garlic
says the tomatoes blister and roast it's
going to take on all this lovely garlic
to give the tomatoes a wonderful sweet
and sour flavor a pinch of sugar and
balsamic vinegar
this is a wonderful age balsamic vinegar
and then some time don't pick the time
just trim it like you're having a little
haircut nice
the tomatoes only take 10 minutes to
roast
now the plant is set it's ready to
griddle
should just fall out beautiful blend is
a nice garnish for grilled Meats it's
great when you're planning a big dinner
party
the Plenty can be done one or two days
before a nice season
top and bottom
a nice sort of coating of olive oil and
then onto your grill
now
this looks very impressive but it's so
easy to do
get that Grill really nice and hot make
sure you've got a fish slice and go
underneath
to turn all that nice sort of marking
and showering the blender gives that
really nice flavor
now tomatoes
no
you've got these beautiful Vine tomatoes
that have been roasted and all that
wonderful flavor
[Music]
now get your little tomatoes and just
sit them on top
drizzle over any remaining roasting
juices
the perfect addition is a goat's curd
goat's curd gives it that nice sort of
salty creamy
taste goat's cheese cream cheese or
creme fraiche will work just as well
drizzle
a little touch
of that age basement vinegar and then a
little basil
I can't wait to dive in
this dish is fantastically entertaining
in the morning set your plan to the
night before and you can have this
casual brunch on the table within
minutes fuss-free cooking that looks
like a labor of love
coming up I've got some great lunch and
dinner recipes when you're cooking for a
crowd
[Music]
but first here's a closer look at some
of the key ingredients you'll need to
impress your friends
[Music]
keep your guests sweet here's some of
the most common sugars and what they're
best for
almost sticky muscovado sugar rich and
trickly in flavor it's great in biscuits
fruit cakes and pickles
powdery icing sugar dissolves without
heat making it perfect for butter creams
and icing
palm sugar made from the palm tree sap
is generally sold as a paste and brings
caramely flavors to Sweet and Savory
dishes
the secret to the meringue I'm serving
my mates for dinner is caster sugar part
way between granulated and icing sugar
in size it dissolves well it's the
ultimate sugar for baking
for the main course I'm using corn fed
chicken you can buy them everywhere
they're great value they have a lovely
color and a rich flavor and with an
incredible stuffing roast chickens
guaranteed to be a crowd pleaser
sea bream and I think the Kilt head
variety with its disco Diva gold flash
is the most flavoursome
to check it's fresh its eyes should be
bright gills red and scales shiny
bream's great poached grilled or pan
fried but I'm going to bake it in a salt
crust for my ultimate lunch for friends
when I'm cooking lunch for a crowd of my
friends my policy is to keep it simple
and think big so instead of making lots
of little things I usually cook a whole
fish or a large joint of delicious meat
that way there's always plenty to go
around now you can have this prepared
and in the oven before any of your
guests arrive it looks super impressive
especially when you bring it to the
table this is my ultimate lunch for
friends
salt crusted Sebring served with braised
leeks and hazelnuts
first job is that salt crust this dish
looks intimidating but it is actually
very straightforward and very easy make
sure the guts are out and the fish is
clean the most important thing is always
leaving the skin and the scales on that
skin protects the actual flesh from
becoming insulting give the fish a
really nice seasoning
inside even though we're putting a salt
crust on the outside it's still very
important to season the middle fennel
seeds
goes brilliantly well with Fish And then
slice the lemon nice large thick slices
the zest
and the lemon bakes inside the fish
fold over the fish and just squeeze the
juice now for the salt
about 150 ml to 200 mL of water
what you're trying to do now is bring
the salt together and you want to sort
of end up with a bowl of salt that looks
almost like snow
you'll need about two kilos of salt for
this and it doesn't need to be the fancy
stuff even though you're using a lot of
it it won't make the fish salty instead
the crust forms a kiln that retains
moisture well basically
a nice bed of salt underneath
flatten it down
lay the fish on top of the salt get your
salt
and just start packing you can salt
crust almost any fish from sea bass to
Salmon or flatfish like soul but it's
not great with oily fish
now it looks like a ridiculous amount of
salt but it's really important to cover
all the fish
because you want that nice shell and the
minute the salt hits the oven it sort of
tightens up and forms this
large crust that goes in at 180 degrees
for 25 to 30 minutes
whilst the fish Cooks is onto my
beautiful braised leaks
splash of olive oil leak is a very sort
of firm robust vegetable so it can take
a really nice Sear
the most exciting thing about these
leeks I either go beautifully for
deceivering but braised leeks colored
properly with a lot of flavor on there
tastes absolutely delicious
take a couple of cloves of garlic and
just crush them in with the leeks some
fresh thyme
get some butter in there
braising them in butter and white wine
gives them the most amazing flavor
braising as a chefy term for searing at
a high temperature then cooking with a
bit of liquid
bring that up to the boil
and then
the rest of your butter
now
as the white wine reduces down the
flavor the leeks intensifying they glaze
turn it down
just leave that little Gap there if we
totally
covered it then you're gonna get all
that condensation underneath the lid and
it'll just make the legs watery the
leaks will take about 12 minutes to cook
so now for the garnish roasted hazelnuts
they'll be roasting the oven very
brittle very firm so get them inside
pestle and mortar bit of seasoning and
just crush your nuts
don't over pound them I just want this
nice sort of rustic chopped toasted
hazelnuts now
get your knife you want that going
through with ease and turn off the gas
all right absolutely adore them
like stunning little parcels
soft and slightly creamy
now baste the leeks with the remaining
butter
spread your fat leaf parsley over
generously
and then just sprinkle
with toasted hazelnuts the combination
of that earthiness from the leeks the
roasted flavor from the hazelnuts that
is a stunning way of eating leeks
and now for the fish
I'm not now just gently tap
top
and it starts falling away you can just
see that beautiful
shine carefully lift off
your salt now peel that skin look how
juicy and succulent that seabream is
stays incredibly moist
the other great thing about cooking
whole fish like this it makes it so easy
to fill it
take a spoon
run that down
through the top
the fish will just slide off
there now
just
push back that lovely fillet and look
at that is cooked beautifully and that's
what keeps them coming back for more
and more and more when you have friends
over you want to keep lunch relaxed lay
back but impressive and a salt crust
brain with beautiful braised leeks is
just that
one of the things I've learned about
running successful restaurants over the
past 20 odd years is it's not just the
food that keeps people coming back you
need to create a great atmosphere too
and it's the same at home
me my ultimate dinner for friends is
utterly delicious but it keeps things
simple and easy in the kitchen
[Music]
helping me in the kitchen proving this
dinner's Child's Play to make is middle
daughter Holly first shop get the
chicken stuffed and roasting
now we all know
you love chicken I did
but we're gonna do it the way that Daddy
used to eat it in Paris okay now I'm
gonna hold that up okay season inside
please why is it yellow because it's a
corn fed chicken obviously eats corn and
if you eat lots of corn yellow turn
yellow now what are those
chickpeas chickpeasia have a little
taste it
nice yeah we're gonna make them taste
even better salt pepper in there as well
please now
chilies
can you hear that noise is that me
seeds have come out
the tops I'm gonna add the chilies the
chickpeas in
and then
zest the lemon in there please you love
your zest I love my zest
the absolutely right a little glug of
olive oil
come on house don't worry about your
nails now come on baby you can do it
now time you pick off all those
wonderful little buds
see
so as we stuff the chicken with the
fresh thyme
the chickpeas become sort of fat and
juicy from all that wonderful flavor
chickpea stuffing done next we're going
to make the herb butter to flavor the
skin now what's that tar again
hmm slightly vinegary yeah yeah a little
bit and a CD yeah so imagine that flavor
going into the chicken that's going to
be delicious now nice soft butter in
with a Target
is that lovely yeah now I want you
gently to put your fingers through there
and just so we can get that butter under
there but I need those small beautiful
little hands
what's wrong it's yucky come on holes
nice well done I want you
get a nice handful of butter
oh
lift your hand up and push under good
now see that there yeah you push it all
the way down there and you let that
slide and that's how you get all that
wonderful
yeah butter running down and the breasts
stay nice and moist and like you
yeah all those chickpeas in there nice
your hands have never been so dirty have
they no here we go
okay now place my lemon in there
right take your garlic should I wash my
hands no not yet we're gonna lay the
garlic
onto the tray now
onto the garlic
salt
pepper make your skin nice and crispy
and then I'm just going to drizzle some
olive oil that'll stop the butter from
burning and look at that
please open the door thank you and she
goes
beautiful good job
thank you really good it's nice to see
Holly get our hands dirty right I think
we all agree huh
for dessert it's an incredible but easy
hazelnut meringue Tower guaranteed to
wow your mates
start with the basic meringue separate
four egg whites
[Music]
and whisk
gradually add caster sugar
[Music]
until the mix forms stiff glossy Peaks
gently folding ground and chopped
hazelnuts
a trick we use in the restaurants is to
use the mix to stick baking sheets down
which makes them easy to spread and
stops the sheets blowing around
top your meringues with more finely
chopped hazelnuts
and bake for 25 minutes
and the trick to stop them cracking is
to turn the oven off and let them cool
inside
for the filling melt dark chocolate in a
bowl over simmering water
and slightly cool
whip the cream until it forms soft peaks
and gently fold in three quarters of the
melted chocolate until combined
build your Tower with alternate layers
of chocolate cream and meringue
[Music]
finally drizzle over the remaining
melted chocolate to decorate
a simple yet luxurious dessert your
friends will love but be warned they'll
all want second helpings
[Music]
the chickens in the oven and the
desserts sorted now for a big easy green
salad
so
let's start off with one nice tablespoon
a nice little squeeze of honey
honey yes and it will Splash
oh
aged
this is your favorite this one isn't it
I just like the it has a nice sweetness
but then it has a better Nest to it too
nice
extra virgin olive oil why do we have to
use a whisk not just a spoon the purpose
of using a whisk is so it can emulsify
but more importantly you're bringing all
the ingredients together taste
um
it's so yummy that is delicious isn't it
tip to loosen any vinaigrette and give
it a lighter taste is to add a spot of
water now the juice of a Lemon Squeeze
the lemon in
nice now use some butter lettuce
start placing the salad around the
outside this one is a Lolo Rosso
okay
so we'll put that one on the inside
we're sort of making a nice flower and
you've got your heart in there
that's exactly what I'm trying to do a
nice beautiful flower now
from there
crisscross your avocado what does
criss-crossing do instead of just close
it down I'll show you now you put your
spoon in there and look that's so cool
all these nice little bits I want you to
sprinkle those little bits in here
I'm telling you that first dinner you
cook for your boyfriend is going to be
extraordinary
that romantic dinner
the roast chicken the beautiful salad
okay yeah to where your father taught
you
and how nice will that be all three of
us sat down eating at the same time very
nice
are you gonna do that with Megan all of
you
all of you and I grabbed the chicken
okay
now
look at this beauty
yeah that looks amazing doesn't it right
so a little bit
drip nice what I'm gonna do now squeeze
all that garlic and see how soft and
beautiful it is smells amazing the lemon
that we stuffed inside the chicken
roasted
what we do now is just squeeze all that
through we've got that nice
garlic puree and tip all my
chickpeas
in there from there some of your vinegar
in
[Music]
now you crush them because they're still
nice hot
absorb all that wonderful garlic and
lemon puree the rich
delicious creamy vinaigrette the chilies
I can guarantee you young lady that they
are the best
the finest the most delicious chickpeas
you've ever tasted
[Music]
go on then it's yummy right
and
now it will drizzle
thanks a virgin olive oil over them
beautifully done
[Music]
on chickpeas and that is a roast chicken
Fit For A King dying this looks really
yummy
how many pasta salad out please an
alcohol chicken whole roast chicken
stuffed with chickpeas serve with a big
green salad it's always a winner with
your buddies work mates or family
chickpeas are really really rich
stuffing is amazing I love chickpeas
because they're like peas from chicks
your first chicken recipe for you and
your boyfriend there are loads more
great home cooking recipes on my app
cook with me you can find it in the App
Store good luck
[Music]
during my career I've worked in some of
the world's best restaurants where every
meal is a special occasion but this type
of food isn't that practical at home
with an ultimate food for special
occasions I'll be showing you some
stunning dishes guaranteed to knock the
socks off anyone but crucially these
dishes are still really easy to pull off
first up one of my family's favorite
breakfast treats Sumptuous eggs benedict
with Crispy Parma ham followed by a dish
fit to take center stage at any special
occasion lunch luscious grilled lobster
served with Bloody Mary linguine the
smell of that chili and garlic butter is
extraordinary and Jack and I cook up the
ultimate Unforgettable dinner for a
Ramsay Clan get together it doesn't get
more memorable than this nice a superb
rare for little beef with salsa verde
and bake new potatoes with an indulgent
twist
I'm a dessert an amazing chocolate and
pistachio semifredo
these are my ultimate recipes for a
special occasion breakfast lunch and
dinner kicking things off with a
beautiful breakfast of eggs benedict
with Crispy Parma ham
the secret behind a great eggs benedict
is in the hollandaise so get your pan on
because I'm going to cook a hollandaise
over a rolling boil with a glass bowl
butter just put it on to melt
three egg yolks
separated from the white
targon vinegar pop that into the eggs if
you can't get turkey vinegar any white
wine vinegar will do just as long as
you've got that acidity in there give
some bite to the hollandaise put your
bowl
over the Rolling Water
and just start whisking
if the eggs had Direct contact with the
gas pollen days will become scrambled
egg
once you've got that nice creamy texture
a nice thick Sauvignon start adding your
butter
nice and slowly
a couple of tablespoons of butter in
and give that a really nice mix
if you don't whisk it enough the egg
yolks don't take the butter it causes it
to split
it's more butter
using a big balloon whisk like this one
makes it easier to incorporate air and
helps prevent your mixture from
separating
all the butter in
the best way to keep hollandaise nice
and warm is just leave it to sit over
that nice warm water bath and it just
gives it a really nice room temperature
a nice pinch of salt
fresh pepper and then fresh lemon juice
that just really makes it vibrant
exciting
I want it like a sort of thick custard I
just want it to coat the back of the
spoon so it's like you're giving the a
nice glossy texture to your beautiful
poached egg now as the base for the eggs
benedict you cannot beat English muffins
but the ham
and we'll change I'm going to use the
most amazing Parma ham get your pan nice
and hot into the pan
it's like Posh rashes of bacon
beautiful
[Music]
ham fried nice and crisp like that is
incredible beautiful in salads fantastic
for eggs Benedict
[Music]
now keep that pan nice and hot I want
all that flavor on the Parma ham left in
there and rather than toast my muffins I
want to put the muffins into the pan I
want them sucking up all that wonderful
flavor from that crispy Parma ham
sure your muffins are toasted nicely
this will prevent them going soggy later
look at that nice and crisp
now water on to boil for the eggs nicely
seasoned really important and then just
a little splash of vinegar in the water
that helps us set the egg white in a
minute you crack it in
while the water heats up in the pan
there's time to get organized lay a nice
slice of ham on the base
now water's brought up to the ball turn
it down and then spin your water around
like a little whirlpool
don't get a little cup so you just drop
the cup in
a look what happens to the egg gets
caught up in the turbulence of the water
the secret is not the ball the water
rapidly because the strength of the ball
can literally explode your egg as they
start to move their way up to the top of
the water that's a indication that
they're cooked take off any excess
little bits of egg white
and then out onto a piece of tissue
paper
that just drains off excess water and it
stops your muffin from going really
soggy but look they're like little
beautiful mozzarella balls give them a
little season
lift them on to a crispy Parma ham
beautiful
now get a nice spoon of your Hollandaise
glaze over
try and do it in one glazing over the
whole egg
when I tell Jack Holly and Megan I'm
Matilda that we're cooking eggs benedict
for breakfast they bolt down the stairs
and let's be honest who wouldn't run to
sit in front of those
no no no
no
special occasion breakfast that would
make anyone feel spoiled eggs benedict
with Crispy Parma ham
[Music]
the key ingredients for my ultimate
special occasion lunch and dinner aren't
cheap
to make sure you get the best value when
you go out shopping here's a closer look
at them
first up for lunch I'll be using one of
the world's ultimate luxury Foods
lobsters not cheap but they're sure to
impress they can they can be bought live
when they usually a greeny brown or blue
color or cooked with their more familiar
red Hue lobsters can grow to almost 5
kilo but the smaller the specimen the
more tender it will be I think three
quarters of a kilo is a good size to go
for if you save the shell it will make
an excellent stock bisque or lobster
sauce
next the Truffle
ounce for ounce they're one of the most
expensive Foods in the world rich and
earthian flavor the price of these
Subterranean Delicacies is determined by
the type shape and size the good news is
a little of these odd looking fungi will
go a long long way I'll be using
shavings of black truffle to raise some
baked potatoes from the ordinary to the
extraordinary
next Sensational beef fillet prized for
its melt-in-the-mouth tenderness this
quick to cook Lean cut comes from the
loin of the animal running along either
side of the backbone look for dry aged
fillet as the beef hangs natural enzymes
break down the tissue making it even
more succulent and flavor some dry aged
beef fillet will be joining my pimped up
truffle potatoes in my superb special
occasion dinner
I don't think home cooking should ever
be difficult even when you're putting
together food for special occasions one
of the key secrets to getting the wow
factor into your food is to buy great
ingredients and let them do the talking
for my ultimate special occasion lunch
I've got some stunning and I mean
stunning lobsters
and I'll be cooking them very simply
with chili and garlic butter serving
them with Bloody Mary linguine
I'm going to start with the pasta sauce
I love the Indulgence in this dish if I
was doing this for the kids I'd scrap
the vodka and just do like a virgin Mary
but it's a bit of a grown-up's fish now
pan nice and hot special olive oil
onions in seasoning Touch of salt and
pepper
garlic be nice and generous with your
garlic it's not just your average tomato
sauce it's a royal stunning tomato sauce
and you're in for a big treat
season the onions and garlic the Tabasco
that'll give that really nice lift
little pinch of celery salt
spice that up with Worcester sauce it
instantly colors the tomatoes goes
brilliantly well with the celery salt
Tabasco and that nice caramelized garlic
a little light sprinkling of sugar all
the Worcester sauce has reduced down
we've got this nice sweet spicy sticky
garlicky onion base glaze with a couple
of spoons of vodka in
lovely
chopped tomatoes in
a little touch of water
look at the color of that sauce check
the seasoning
[Music]
bring that up to the ball and cook it
out six to eight minutes reduce it down
slowly turn down the Gas let that simmer
with my sauce simmering I can move on to
a delicious breadcrumb topping to dress
my linguine
fly off my bed cars get them nice and
crispy but don't put too much oil in
there otherwise the bread will just
absorb it and become greasy
beautifully season them
and they go really nice and golden brown
30 seconds before they come out flat
leaf parsley roll that through your
bread crumbs and that is going to finish
the linguine on top
you can hear how crisper they are
before I cook the linguine I'm going to
make the chili butter that will flavor
my Lobster
get your chili and slice it I want to
take advantage of all those seeds
trillion touch your soul
a nice clove of garlic
and here's some parsley
[Music]
start breaking that down but I'm looking
for a lovely garlic chili paste exactly
like that now don't overdo it with the
butter
her Butters are a great way to flavor
fish and meat they can be used as a
stuffing in dishes like chicken kiev or
added towards the end of a Dish as a
delicious glaze
lobsters
they're already cooked so
firmly placed Lobster flat on your board
there's a little crisscross here lying
there and a line going across put the
point of the knife in and just push
through
the head turn the lobster around
cut through the lobster
snap the legs off
snap the claws off just get the back of
your knife
crack them
spread that beautiful butter on
go into the heads as well
and then the claws take off bits of the
shell
and get a little bits of butter in there
this can be done way in advance for me
the longer that chili butter sits on top
of that Lobster the better the flavor
especially when they hit the grill
while my Lobster firms up in the fridge
I can finish cooking my linguine water
brought up to the boil
seasoned nicely and a little touch of
olive oil now linguine in first that's
going to take the longest eight to ten
minutes in
as linguine starts softening at the
bottom just gently turn that around
always wait the linguine is nice and
soft that way you don't break those nice
strands give that a good mix get your
lid back on
[Music]
and bring that to the ball rapidly
after eight to ten minutes my linguine
should be perfect you want it Al Dente
slightly firm
um not too chewy absolutely spot on
drain that into a colander shake a
little bit of water from the pasta into
my sauce
and she goes start twisting
linguine round I want that Bloody Mary
spicing up the linguine
always hold up the center of the pan
first and place it onto the plate let go
of that nice big lump
by doing this you'll get a mountainous
pile of spaghetti with more body then
generously cover that with your crispy
breadcrumbs absolutely beautiful
[Music]
last but not least I need to cook my
chilled herb buttered lobsters on a
smoking hot griddle
that Butter's gone really nice and firm
so the idea is
snapping that down
and grilling
the smell of that chili and garlic
butter is extraordinary because the
lobsters cooked all you're doing is
grilling that delicious spicy chili
butter you just want that Mark of the
Char quickly on the lobster
turn that over
smell is incredible
[Music]
um get that on
you can understand why it is proper
special occasion food because that is
mind-blowing
griddled Lobster with chili and garlic
butter served with a boozy Bloody Mary
linguine a sensational special occasion
lunch
[Music]
in my restaurants the kitchens are
divided into different sections there's
a section that cooks fish and fish only
another for the meat and so on
the chefs become so good because they're
constantly improving all the time
practice makes perfect so if you get a
chance give my ultimate special occasion
dinner a trial run before you cook it on
your big nights
on the menu is a succulent rare beef
fillet with salsa Valley served with
roasted truffle new potatoes the dish is
designed to make your special occasion
one to remember
and to end our Ramsay get together with
a bang I've enlisted willing sous chef
Jack to help me make us a blind
chocolate and pistachio semifredo
now I know you love chocolate right
we'll break this up so it melts nice and
evenly
all right that goes over memory you
can't put the chocolate in direct
contact with the gas yeah okay otherwise
it will split crack four eggs in
everything of course hold one like that
on the side and then your fingers in
and pull out okay good
nice now you're cracking eggs with one
hand hey
nice one I need some muscles okay start
whisking and I'll fold in a bit of sugar
come on let's do 30 seconds each Freddy
okay come on Jack give it some 13 year
old Welly come on some muscles
10 seconds to go nine eight seven six
five four three two one right here go
your temperature let's go
you see the secret the whisking
vigorously is changing hands every 10
seconds yep now I'm gonna stir the
chocolate I'll stir that for you
now the secret behind this is getting it
really nice and thick and that's like a
stabbing on okay your turn come on
change change again yeah of course also
the chocolate leave that to slightly
cool down a touch
foreign
why put in the cumin separately because
I'm gonna get it nice and thick first if
you start whisking that I'm going to get
in the vanilla to maximize the flavor
from a vanilla bean Cut the pot in half
lengthways and scrape out those
wonderfully aromatic seeds for extra
flavor put the pod in as well but
remember to take it out once it's
infused
so we've got three components the melted
chocolate yes sugar yes and the eggs
whipped up and the cream with the
vanilla next mix in your melted
chocolate with the sugar and egg Sabayon
so you've got a nice rich chocolate
ganache smell how delicious that is
I'm now I'm putting the cream and so you
just
whisk that in now look at that how
gorgeous is that looking and that my son
is a chocolate semifreddo now a little
taste
[Music]
sprinkle them in
now get your baking tray you line that
with clinical so it's easy to pull out
once it sets and then you just pull that
in
it's a real treat
so you fold that over okay this is like
ice cream in any way yeah as it sets you
slice it it's like this nice chocolate
ice block delicious
then put your semifredo into the freezer
for around three hours to set right jack
get that pan nice and hot recognize that
this is a Rolls-Royce not beef so we've
got to treat it with some respect okay
yeah mop up all that seasoning yeah into
the pan and get that really nice and hot
hello tails
my kiss and
what's that holes what's the name
Rosemary a little bit of garlic and
Thyme in there
cooking with these aromatic herbs and
garlic will add flavor to the beef
because it's a fillet of beef
there's hardly any fat on there so you
sear it quickly ends as well just see it
I'm gonna now put some butter in there
continue frying all those herbs now
baste that with the butter see
I mean this or we're gonna have some
now we're going to serve some beautiful
baked potatoes with truffle and a salsa
verde into the oven eight to ten minutes
that's all
next my super special baked new potatoes
wash and drain small new potatoes and
tip into a baking tray
drizzle with olive oil then season with
a touch of salt and freshly ground black
pepper Place into an oven preheated at
180 degrees Celsius and bake for 35
minutes until crisp on the outside and
soft all the way through
transfer to your serving dish and Grate
over fresh Parmesan cheese
last but not least shave gorgeous earthy
black truffle slivers onto the cheesy
potatoes
baking potatoes with a lavish twist
indulgent but couldn't be simpler to
make
right salsa birthday anchovies little
touch of anchor of your oil in there
okay
after that we've got some capers
garlic
in with the anchovies and the Capers
okay A Touch
of salt whining a touch because you've
got yourself that's right Dijon mustard
show vinegar give it a nice mix and now
this is where it starts to go to a
completely different level some fresh
mint and some fresh parsley I want half
of it in there pureed a touch of olive
oil in there in
the rest of the mint
salt pepper
excited
no taste sauce
what's it taste like fat
might need to try a tiny bit more
just to check stop don't kiss any boys
now before the kids polish off all the
salsa verde I need a distraction and I
think my B fillet will do the job nicely
look at this baby hot holes
up
look at that
says and look how juicy and tender that
is take that out and let that sit on
there a little spoon just while it sits
and rests of yourself so badly as the
beef cools down that's salsa verde
marinades that goes to the table very
carefully please Tails taking over the
baked potatoes please right semi Friday
now
look at that it's nice
[Applause]
wow and they just get the chocolate
can you grate it
over
[Music]
[Applause]
how delicious is that let's get one Do
not drop that please
Jack
this is my ultimate special occasion
dinner the tenderest rare beef fillet
with Punchy salsa verde
served with extravagant truffle new
potatoes
and a Sublime chocolate and pistachio
semifredo
it's always a special occasion in our
house and my wonderful mum and her
husband Jimmy turn up for dinner sit
down guys
[Music]
this is a definite special occasion
Cheers Cheers nice to see you
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck